I'm an economic theorist I'm mostly
interested not in particular topics in
economics but in how economists do their
business which is what theorists do so
this is may seem a little dry but you
know this is what one end of the
business school does when they want to
talk about how the discipline does what
it does in particular I'm gonna give you
a look at the research program I've been
on it's a little short on details it's
gonna be long on slides and I have 55
minutes to get through this what is it
about well my research program is about
dynamic choice economists have a way
I'll describe that way in a bit as to
how to model deal with dynamic choice
when they go out and try and understand
dynamic choices that people make I'm
interested in providing economists with
more realistic more consistent was
observed behavior models of dynamic
choices that's the research program now
to understand what that means and why
there's an issue here we've got to take
a step back and the step back is to talk
about how economics as a discipline
works so let's do that economists do two
things they talk about people sometimes
firms making choices not any choices but
consistent choices so a lot of the
subject is about what's called choice
theory how does this person choose how
does that person choose what's the basis
on which they choose always with
consistent choices and then they talk
about how those choices are equilibrated
in various institutional settings
normally markets but increasingly other
institutional settings Mike Harrison how
many people here know Mike Harrison okay
so Mike Harrison who's just recently
retired another institution in the
school or an institution in the school
describes these two pieces as the first
is the theory of cats and the second is
the theory of cats in a bag so you
should think of that now economists are
somewhat what's the word they'd like to
extend their influence wherever they can
and so they sometimes instead of calling
them inconsistent choices they say it's
rational choices and I think it's a bad
you know the implied pejorative is
that choices that don't conform to the
economic model are irrational
that's bad language I'd like to avoid
that language I'm gonna use the word
consistent choices so there's choices
and then there's equilibration I'm all
about the choices part of the subject so
what is consistent choice to an
economist it's everything but the
following so a man walks into a roadside
diner and says I want a piece of pie and
a cup of coffee please
waitress says we have apple and peach
pie today guy says in that case I'd like
a piece of apple pie she says I just
remembered we have one slice of banana
cream left as well and he says you also
have banana cream well in that case give
me peach okay right that's the one thing
that economists don't want to deal with
ok consistent choice is everything but
what that guy just did now it's more
formal I'm formally if an economic agent
chooses an object X and not Y when both
of them are available then she never
chooses why when X is available having
shown that she likes sex more than Y she
should always like X more than Y that's
consistent choice to an economist and as
long as that property holds we can model
her choice this is a mathematical
theorem we can maximize for choices as
this she's maximizing a numerical
function that map's every option into a
number and she's going to take whatever
option has the biggest number now there
are some technical conditions they have
to meet for that really to follow from
just that property there but they're not
very stiff conditions in particular if
the universe of things you can choose is
finite the only thing you have to add to
that condition the formally condition is
that you give her a set of objects to
choose from and she says ok I'll have
this one or if you prefer this one or
this one she makes a choice she doesn't
stand there and say oh I can't choose
that plus the first thing that means you
can model her choices if she's
maximizing utility and that's what
economists do they say consumers are
utility maximizers now in special
I'm stances especially when there's
uncertainty in the world we might make
more structural assumptions on the
nature of her choice say that she
maximizes expected utility or subjective
expected utility but by and large the
essence of economic choice is that level
of consistency nothing else now
empirically it doesn't work and a good
example comes from the marketing
literature designer of her mail-order
catalog says you know he's trying to
design a web page or a catalog page to
get you to pay $200 to buy a particular
printer he wants you to choose the
printer over keeping $200 in your pocket
so how does he do that well he might do
one of two things
he'll advertise two printers on the page
but one he wants you to buy for 200 and
the second one which has a few more
features at a much higher price and
you're supposed to include Wow that's
$200 printer is a great deal you know I
only get a little bit more for 350
I'll buy the $200 printer or going the
other way he advertises the printer he
wants you to buy and a second much worse
printer for $190 so he said yeah I just
had to spend 10 more dollars I get all
these extra features that $200 printer
is a great deal now that guy who's
designing there the web page here is
exactly playing on the frame that you
put the choice into which is the one
thing economists don't like they don't
want the frame to influence your choice
so you know this is just like the
availability of banana cream pie seemed
to frame the choice between apple and
peach in a way that got the guy to
change what he's doing that's what
you're doing there and people do that
nonetheless economists say no they don't
right economic models by and large have
kept to the consistent choice model of
individual behavior because they say
once we admit that frames change what
you're doing there's not much we can say
about your choices so economists ignore
that kind of stuff which the marketing
people love because that way they make
fun of us but economists believe in
consistent choice as a good way to
attack problems of economic choice in
the world
now what's thy namet choice right that's
the subject I'm interested in I if I'm
choosing a
kind of pi to unity rail would slide
just restaurant or whether to buy a
particular printer that's a static
choice right at the moment I have a
choice between different things I choose
to spend my money on the printer I
choose to have apple pie or peach pie or
whatever it happens it's over if we're
talking about what career you're gonna
follow or where to go to school or how
much you're gonna save that's more of a
dynamic choice first of all the choice
you make today is going to affect the
opportunities you have tomorrow for
future choices and today's choice needs
to be informed about the value that
you've attached to tomorrow's
opportunities or lack of opportunities
so it's that kind of choice the choice
of career how much to save where to go
to school those are dynamic choices
because they have implications going
forward in the future those are the kind
of choices that I'm interested in now
how do economist model dynamic choice
well they use the statically optimized
strategically and then just do it or
such swoosh approach what is this
approach well it starts off with
modeling the problem the choice problem
the individual has so you have a
decision maker who faces a dynamic
decision problem there are choices to be
made today but also tomorrow next month
next year we have a bunch of dates at
which the decision maker has to make
choices that's the start there are
connections between the choices what you
choose today will have an influence on
what options you're going to have to
choose tomorrow and the day after that
and the day after that so your choices
today not only impact what you get today
but what choices you'll have in the
future while you're making these choices
information may arrive that you can use
and use in making later choices so you
think about what information am I going
to get later on and your choices today
can affect what information you do or do
not yet so it's a very complex structure
that economists will start by modeling
that's the dynamic decision problem the
person has and for every dynamic
decision problem there's a range of
strategies that the person can do things
that say well today I'm going to choose
this option and tomorrow if I get this
information between now and tomorrow
I'll make this choice if I get this
other information on
that choice a fool what I'm going to do
for the rest of my life in all the
situations that I'm gonna have to make
choices that's a strategy and we first
formulate all the strategies that we
have in this decision problem and then
every strategy we have Maps into an
outcome how much I get to eat today
tomorrow the next day possibly the
outcome is random there's uncertainty in
the world in which case we think of the
distribution over our consumption over
many days as the outcome the the outcome
is the distribution of possible
consumption streams we have and what we
do as in this socks whoosh approach is
we say okay here's a strategy let me
write a little bit on the board so
here's my decision problem with a whole
bunch of structural stuff and that gives
us a set of strategies now each strategy
gives us an outcome what we're gonna get
so that's outcome from strategy number
one this is the outcome from strategy
number seven million three hundred
twenty one thousand I mean lots of
strategies a typical decision problem in
the finance literature goes on forever
you have an infinite number of
strategies and what you do is for every
strategy you have over here you figure
out what will be the outcome for me and
then you say I've got preferences or
utility over the outcomes so that I look
at every strategy I could do I look at
what outcome it produces I look at how
good an outcome that is for me I figure
out that this is the outcome or the yeah
this is the outcome and of all the
possible outcomes I could have from all
the possible strategies that's the
outcome that max
is my utility which means this is the
best strategy to play that's what I'm
gonna do and then mindlessly I just
implement that strategy through time so
you choose at the outset right we're
sitting at this decision problem I'm
about to choose where to go to school
that has an impact on my career I think
through the entire scheme of my life
what's gonna happen to me for the next
you know sixty years what are the
strategies I could have for 60 years
what's the outcome from every strategy
which of those outcomes do I like the
best that means I should go to Dartmouth
where I went once I have that strategy
in mind I just do it that's the judge
that's the swoosh part of this that's
the way economists model dynamic choice
at the outset pick a strategy pick an
optimal strategy based on the outcomes
and just implement I this is viewed by
economists as obvious this is how you
would make the right decision and it's
so obvious you know I've written a
couple of economics textbooks in every
economics textbooks I've ever written I
discuss the problem of dynamic choice
and what is the standard approach I
don't call it solution in the books but
that's essentially what it is and it's
the only textbook so they never discuss
it's everybody else says well it's
obvious that's what you're gonna do it's
just unworthy to talk about the
assumptions that go in to this
particular way of viewing dynamic choice
so know before I get to that that nobody
really believes that people sit down
trying to pick a college thinking
through their entire lifetime it's an as
if model and the idea there is that it's
not how people think about things but
the way they behave is as if that's what
they did a good example here is you go
back to a utility maximization the basic
model of economics I mean you've read an
economics textbook it says when you go
over to the grocery store you got money
in your pocket you got a list of things
you might buy you consult your utility
function you consult your budget
constraint you optimize subject to a
budget that nobody
that right you go down the aisle with
your cart you look at something you say
that looks good I'll put that in the
cart you know occasionally what happens
is you go down another aisle you say oh
that looks even better and you go back
to the aisle and put something back you
make your choices sort of as you go
along
well economists say ok that's how you
make choices but it's as if when you're
in Safeway you're maximizing your
utilities subject to a budget constraint
it's not how you think about it but it's
the net result of what you do and
there's a famous analogy which is due to
Milton Friedman that says that well let
me give you a good example of an as if
model trees in the spring decide where
to put their leaves and as good as if
model of how trees set their leaf canopy
is as if they're maximizing their
exposure to Sun over the course of a day
now trees don't really do the
calculation right I mean trees have
trouble with simple sums but if you
model the setting of a leaf canopy as if
a tree was maximizing it it turns out to
be a pretty good and useful model of how
the tree will set up its leaf canopy so
this is viewed as an as if model it's
not how people make choices people don't
sit down and think about things this way
but their choices are as if they do this
and so maybe that works at Safeway
there's empirical evidence on both sides
evidence that says yet people roughly
conform as if they were maximizing
utility subject to a budget constraint
the marketing guys come in and tell us
about the way they design male model
catalogs to make this model not work but
in particular the question I've asked
for you know many years now is is a good
as if model of dynamic choices or
something about the dynamics of the
choice that says that the socks whoosh
approach is not a good as if model so
that's what I'm interested in is not so
much what's the answer to that question
I say the answer to that question is no
it's really what are the reasons it's
not a good model and then what are you
going to do about it
so I've got three reasons that I think
it's not a good as if model of dynamic
choice first of all people's tastes
change
you're making a decision here where to
go to school stuff like that well you
know three years down the line you may
decide you know I thought that's where
the path I wanted to follow but it's not
I'm gonna follow a different path and
I'll get back to this in a minute it has
to and to some extent contradictory
consequences for the nature of decisions
I make as I go along the fact that I
recognize that my taste will change
there are things that you can't
anticipate sitting here thinking about
what you're gonna do for the rest of
your life when you're choosing where to
go to school you know something
unanticipated is going to happen to you
you know in your sophomore year let
alone five years out on the job and the
actions you take today take account of
the fact that you know there are things
you can't anticipate so that's reason
number two and third you know this
problem is just too hard to think about
it's too complex you can't really do the
optimization you know so this is
strategy seven million three hundred
twenty one thousand etcetera I mean
there are an infinite number of
strategies and nobody in most realistic
problems can figure out which is the
best according to some numerical measure
so you couldn't do this if you wanted to
if you had all the data instead what
people do is they follow your ristic
decision rules and those through your
stick decision rules can't always be
justified using this approach if you use
your ristic decision rule it's not as if
you are solving an optimization problem
like this so in each of those three what
I do now is talk about each of those
three what there is and a little bit
about what I've worked on in that
particular regard so first of all
changing tastes now you can't doubt
people's tastes change was time passes
you plan you're gonna do something in
the middle you say you know I don't want
to do that anymore I'm gonna go do
something else I do that a lot now the
question is if you know your tastes are
gonna change is that going to affect
what you do today and there are three
options at least an economic modeling
that you have to say three answers to
the question
what are you gonna do about it today
knowing that your tastes may change one
option is nothing what you say is well
my taste might change I don't care today
I'm gonna figure out what I think is
best for me given my taste today I'll
keep going until my tastes change and
then I'll change my plan a little bit
more sophisticated is you constrain your
later choices so you get what you want
today and this goes the the original
story here comes from the Odyssey
when Odysseus is going past the Isle of
the sirens he knows that once he hears
the siren song his tastes are gonna
change he's gonna throw himself off so
he constrains himself he has them tie
him he has his sailors tie him to the
mast so that he can't have the option of
throwing himself off the ship later on
more modern examples that people talk
about in as one deals with me is I try
to make sure that there isn't any sweet
food in the refrigerator late at night
because I know if it's there late at
night my will will get weaker and I'll
start eating that stuff
one of the original papers on this was
about Christmas clubs why do people you
know do people even know what a
Christmas Club is anymore haven't even
know what a Christmas Club is okay so
for those of you who don't used to be a
big thing at least when I was being
raised in New Jersey a long time ago is
that the banks would very happily take
some money from you every week or every
month and not let you have it until two
weeks before Christmas the idea idea
being is that you know if you start
putting money away in a regular bank
account you can always withdraw it and
then the money won't be there for
Christmas but if you put the money in a
Christmas Club you can't touch it until
it's time to go by the Christmas
presents this is a way to force yourself
to save and not spend the money and the
banks used to love this because it paid
no interest I mean you know this way the
banks are holding your money for you
not letting you have access to it well
that's exactly this idea that you know
you'd know at some point you might want
to spend the money that you're saving
for Christmas presents so we'll make
sure you can't get at it
well you've constrained yourself by
going there now a very recent
then pretty large literature about this
is about hyperbolic discounting
hyperbolic discounting is the following
phenomenon I give you a choice between
so this is a choice between $100 today
or let's see what's a good number a
hundred and twenty next week so I give
you that choice a lot of people I don't
know if I quite got the right numbers
here but a lot of people say well I
prefer a hundred dollars today but if I
give you the choice of a hundred dollars
in 51 weeks or a hundred and twenty in
52 weeks then people say well you know
51 weeks 52 weeks what difference does
it make twenty dollars is good so they
go that way and the problem is is that
in 51 weeks if I offered you the choice
of a hundred dollars today or in twenty
next week it say oh I made a mistake
I want the hundred dollars today so
that's hyperbolic discounting it it's as
time passes you put a lot of weight on
immediate consumption versus next week
the difference between 51 weeks and 52
weeks isn't as great and that's going to
shift as you get closer and closer to 51
and 52 weeks out now what are the
consequences of this well it affects how
much money you save the form you save it
in in particular today if you think that
you know your preferences 451 versus 52
weeks all right you want to lock in
money that you save so that you don't
pull the money out with a big penalty
stuff like that subject of some okay so
you could do nothing you can constrain
your later choices on the other hand
with sort of the exact opposite you say
look I don't know what my future tastes
are gonna be but what's important to me
today is to give myself the option to do
what's best for myself well
think will be best for myself later on
so this goes with the following sort of
story you're making reservations at a
restaurant you're not gonna go to this
restaurant for three weeks so you're
making reservations way in advance how
big a menu of choices
so today you're picking the menu of the
restaurant and suppose there was menu
one and menu 2 you look at menu one you
say yeah you know there's some good
stuff there menu - there's some good
stuff there on balance I prefer menu one
- menu two so this one is better but if
there was a super restaurant that had
menu one and two all in the same menu
why not go with this in case something
on that menu three weeks from now is
going to have a lot of appeal to me so
that's you know I'd prefer for
flexibility I want to leave myself the
flexibility to make a choice later on
because I don't know what my tastes are
gonna be I don't know what my preference
gonna be later on but I don't want to
constrain myself today I would allow my
later self to have what at once so
that's completely different from number
two number two you're saying what I want
today is what I want to force myself
later on to have now you're saying well
what I'm gonna want later on is what I
should allow myself to have two
different very different ways of dealing
with the idea that tastes are changing
so my interest in this the constrain
your later self the thing that goes with
hyperbolic discounting and Christmas
clubs it's a big important topic lots of
work has been done in economics not me
this is not something I've ever worked
on instead I work on the two other
things the two other directions the
leave yourself flexibility direction
well paper I wrote back in 1979 a long
time ago says okay if you think your
tastes are going to change exactly what
is the form that this preference for
flexibility will take so trying to say
mathematically how do I put together a
formal model which is what economists do
and I put together a formal model of
this kind
preference for flexibility where it's
being driven by the fact I don't know
what my future tastes will be and I want
to give my later self the chance to make
a choice so that's one thing I've worked
one the other thing is something I'm
working on right now which I find very
fascinating this is comes out of my 10
years as senior associate dean I'm very
interested in motivation and how do you
motivate people now you you know you
guys deal with the faculty so it won't
surprise you to learn that they're a
hard group to manage right I know it
won't surprise you in particular you
know as senior associate dean you got
the job of motivating them to do what's
good for the school and not what they
want to do necessarily and so I've spent
a lot of time thinking about motivation
especially in the context of the faculty
now economists if you go to an economist
and you say okay we're talking about
motivation on the job motivating faculty
members of the GSB to spend time
thinking about their teaching actually
put some effort into teaching the MBAs
not spending all their time doing
research or whatever else it is they do
you say to an economist I've got a
question about motivation on the job an
economist the standard economist says I
know the answer to your question the
answer to your question is incentives
right economists have one answer the
motivation which is pay them more money
if they do good stuff that's it so this
is the economists answer promised more
money if the employee does good stuff
the problem with this theory of
incentives it's a theory that is very
important in economics it's one of the
things I think we're now up to like
three Nobel Prizes give
for various aspects of the theory of
incentives the big issue in incentive
theory is when good stuff happens do you
know that it's because of what the
employee did if there's uncertainty
between what the person tries to do and
what the outcome actually is promising
the more money if they do good stuff
well but it should say if the employee
seems to have done good stuff and that
introduces uncertainty into the employee
about their compensation if I tell my
fellow employ my fellow instructors or
fellow professors I will pay you more
money if you I'll give you a bonus if
your teacher ratings are very high they
can try to get their teacher ratings
very high but it might not work and they
don't like the uncertainty in their
compensation worse than that another
problem with this is that if I tell them
you know I'll give you a lot more money
if your ratings get high what are they
gonna do they're gonna start pandering
to the students I don't want them to
pander to the students it says I can't
tell whether the high ratings are due to
pandering or to the fact that they're
actually teaching a better course so
there's an economic theory of incentives
which for the kind of job at least
faculty members have and a lot more jobs
besides including you know the kind of
jobs you have it doesn't really work
very well it works a little bit but not
very well
that's what economists do now go across
the street to my friends and obey it is
particularly the social psychologists
they have very different theories about
motivation I have theories that say I
talked about self-determination and
self-perception and imprinting let me
give you an illustration of this which
is a hospital in Boston called Beth
Israel I had anybody here from Boston no
okay no Boston has a lot of hospitals in
particular there's a there's a little
district of town known as the hospital
district which has Massachusetts General
and Brigham and Women's and Beth Israel
and there's one more of the forest
hospital called Deaconess all of these
are the Harvard Medical School teaching
hospitals they are the hospitals with
you know people who are at Harvard
Medical School go and staff they take
rounds their stuff like that
residents at these hospitals are
connected to the Harvard Medical School
stuff like that now it's very clear in
the 1970s when this story begins that
there was a clear pecking order amongst
these hospitals and it was Mass General
was the best forgiving woman's number
two Beth Israel three Deaconess number
four and everybody agreed you know the
press these positions were in Mass
General new guy comes to Beth Israel a
CEO guy named Rabkin this is around 1972
I think and he wants to move up in the
pecking order so he's trying to figure
out what can I do to make Beth Israel
stand out and maybe be as sort of as
good as Mass General and he hit on a
system of we're gonna become so his
theory or his strategy is become the
hospital patients prefer so he's going
to emphasize service to the patients and
in particular the way he did this is he
went to the senior orange the senior
registered nurses and he said we're
gonna do nursing differently here we are
going to have what's called primary
nursing if a patient comes and is gonna
be a hot patient at Beth Israel that
person is assigned a primary nurse it's
like you meet your doctor you meet your
primary nurse you sit down and your
primary nurse and I'll use she because
most of them were she's at the time your
primary nurse is dealing with you and
maybe two possibly three other
at any one time when she is on duty for
aid that her 8-hour shift she's doing
everything for you she's managing your
care she's cleaning up your bed stuff
like that but she's also the center of
your care the doctors talked to her
about what needs to be done next for you
when she's off duty the the the 16 hours
a day she's off duty she's still on call
if there's an issue about you you know
primary nurses would get phone calls at
3:00 in the morning saying the family of
one of your patients has a concern talk
to them okay now did they give the
nurses more money for doing this no and
the net result of this is that the
nurses loved it they thought this was
great the cue to become a primary nurse
that best Israel for people who are
nurses at Mass General Brigham ER
woman's just got bigger and bigger and
better what they did is they enriched
the job content being a nurse you were
doing something or doing something
important you are getting psychological
rewards for doing that something
important and the nurses responded
really really well to that now it's a
great story except there's a very bad
outcome a bad ending which is primary
Nursing is a little more expensive and
as times change
subsequent CEOs said well we've got to
get rid of primary nursing it's too
expensive given the way we're
compensated and as you can imagine it
was a disaster they made a psychological
count contract with the nurses which
they then broke and breaking a
psychological contract as much well okay
so this all fits in with the
psychological theory of
self-determination which says people
will give you better output employees
will give you better output if they have
more self-determination if they're doing
something is important they perceive as
important if they're connected to other
people doing the same sort of thing and
also with the theory of self perception
which is people when they do stuff they
try and figure out after the fact why
did I behave in this particular way if
they did it because they got a bonus
they say I'm doing it for the money and
then they will continue to do things for
the money whatever it takes to get the
bonus is what they'll do
if on the other hand they say they do it
because my patients are important to me
or because I love the work they will
increasingly love the work they will
think that their patients are there will
internalize the welfare of their
patients work well that from economic
terms as social psychologists don't
think of it this way but from a point of
view of economics what is that that's
what you do and how you do it and what
rewards you get for it changes your
tastes changes your utility function so
one of the projects I'm working on and
not meeting with greatest success
because my colleagues in economics
really don't like to talk about change
and taste that much but what I'm trying
to do is convince them that things like
this are real they're important and you
know I won't go into all the ways I
tried to manipulate my colleagues when I
was associate dean but I was trying you
know this is more important motivational
force than the stuff that economists say
is important but if you want to talk
about it in economic terms you have to
talk about changing taste and the way
people's tastes change what changes them
how do they change and that takes you
from economics into psychology you got
to understand social psychology
cognitive psychology and try to import
that to economics so one of the things
that I'm doing right now one of the
things that I think is very important
for economics is to try and do better on
how taste change and then what's the
impact on that for dynamic choice okay
so that's number one changing tastes
unanticipated contingencies in the
swooosh model every contingency that
might ever be realized is anticipated
and each one is given its probability
this has probability 110 million this
one has probability one in a thousand
you do a grand optimization over all
those things now formally you could have
things that you don't anticipate it's
just that you make no allowance for them
in the decisions you make today because
they have zero probability you thought
now there's a some branch of economics
called transaction cost economics one of
the great pioneers of this is a guy up
in Berkeley named Ollie Williamson
and point out Ollie got the Nobel Prize
for all the work you did on transaction
cost economics which says you know the
standard economic model the sauce
model applied to relationships between
two firms or relationships between an
employee and employer doesn't make any
sense because the world is not driven by
the things you can anticipate it's
driven by the things you can't
anticipate in a long-term relationship
and so what's important in understanding
when a relationship will be efficient or
not is not what do you plan is going to
happen but how do you plan to meet the
things that you didn't anticipate
that's what transaction cost economics
is all about it's about the governance
structure which is who has which
decision rights when decisions later on
have to be made that you didn't
anticipate so you know that's what
unanticipated that's why unattended
unanticipated contingencies is important
and my contribution is I go back to this
paper I talked about before about
preference for flexibility viewed one
way say I want to model the idea that my
taste will change what are the
consequences for the choices I make over
menus this goes the other way it says if
I see the choices that you make over
menus and you have preference for
flexibility what are the consequences
for how I model your choices what sort
of expected utility model model do I use
and soap does paper 1979 follow up
papers in 86 and 92 I won't go into a
lot of details about this because this
is all business for me but trying to
come to grips with the idea that there
are unintended contingencies that you
prepare for very important in economics
in long-term relationships very
important to dynamic choice and not
something that economists have been very
good at would the exception of the
people who follow Olli and I finally
there's complexity in your wrists Excel
is the issue here well most dynamic
decision problems are amazingly complex
in fact they're far too complex for any
economist to solve so when you have
papers in economics that talk about
dynamic decision problems you have one
of two choices you either assume that
the consumers in your model your model
of economy are solving problems that you
know you could never solve and there's a
whole literature literature on general
equilibrium that assumes people sitting
here today at the fan
this way two people sitting here are
making portfolio decisions making
projections of future prices of things
nobody can make those projections but we
assume our agents can and we derive
results based on the assumption that
they can know okay or when you want to
be a little more structural you only
deal with the kinds of problems that you
can solve which is tremendously limiting
in the range of dynamic decision
problems the economists will actually
talk about so let me give you an example
of a problem that's pretty simple to
describe and pretty difficult to solve
contemplate hiring staff for a
professional service firm that takes one
project so you are in charge of hiring
the staff for this professional services
firm as you look at the potential
employees you're unsure how valuable
different candidates will be so you've
got a bunch of candidates there they are
and they all are carrying their CDs and
they all have letters of recommendation
so that's not going to tell you exactly
how good they're gonna be and it's
certainly not going to tell you how well
they'll work together will this guy with
this CV and the sleaze letters
recognition well these people work well
together or not so how do you find out
who's good who's not well you hire them
you set them to work and you see how it
goes so the question is you look at the
Seavey's you look at what information
you have you know you're gonna have
complete information and then you got to
decide who do I hire okay very standard
problem and it's not just hiring people
it's what tools do you use what assets
do you provide for yourself I questions
at the outset is how many people do you
hire on your team do you want to build
in some redundancy and in particular
suppose you need you know there's this
particular specialty so these people are
part of a specialty you need one person
on your team with that specialty you've
got let's say three candidates you don't
know which one of those three candidates
is going to be the best so should you
hire two of them and find out
so you just hire one and hope that
person works at understanding that if
you hire one person and they work out
okay you got no information about how
those two guys are going to do if you
hire two of them at least you'll have
information about how good each of them
is and then you can make a choice very
simple problem to describe impossible to
solve you cannot solve if I formally
describe this with a model with
uncertainty stuff like that this is an
example of what's called a multi-armed
bandit problem okay and just see anybody
heard the term before one two okay so
what is a multi-armed bandit problem
cold multi-armed bandit problem because
it's about a slot machine so here is a
slot machine in Las Vegas which has the
following weird characteristic for slot
machine there's an arm on this side and
there's an arm on this side and here's
the slot where you put your money you
put your coin you put your coin in and
that enables you to pull one arm or the
other but you can't pull both now you
don't know what is the return from this
arm of the Bandit you don't know what
the return is from that arm of the
Bandit and the only way you can get
information is by pulling the arm so
suppose let's take a very simple case
suppose you knew that this arm wins oh
ten percent of the time and you think
this arm wins five percent of the time
or fourteen percent of the time and each
of those is equally likely well then if
you're only gonna pull one arm once this
arm is better on average but if you got
a little bit of time maybe you want to
try this arm a few times collect
statistics on how often it wins and see
you know am I getting the 14 percent
machine because then I know that's the
Machine I want to play
that's the
I want to play that's a multi-armed
bandit problem is you got a course of
different actions you could take you're
not sure what the returns from each
course of action is and the only way to
find out is to try it well this is a
multi-armed bandit problem now the
solution how do you optimally play the
multi-armed bandit this was a very
difficult problem for years and years
when I started in 1975 sort of at the
business school when I was in graduate
school 1972 this was an unsolved problem
in any sense nobody knew how to solve
this problem and then a guy came along
and Gittins
who said well in the very special case
where there's no information about this
arm in what goes on there and vice versa
where the arms the uncertainty about
them is independent you don't learn
anything about one arm by pulling
another arm then here's how you solve
the problem and it's a beautiful
solution I mean it's a brilliant piece
of work that problem is this is the
multi-armed bandit problem where the
arms are the different teams you could
assemble and those are certainly not
independent if I hire this guy and this
guy and this guy I learn a hell of a lot
about the performance of a team that
just consists of those two so they're
not independent nobody has a clue how to
solve this problem and you know there's
good reason to believe computer
scientist so our guys have been working
on this problem
good good reason to believe that no one
will ever be able to solve these until
we get computers which are much faster
much faster than any computer we have
today so what are you going to do about
this
well people will use heuristics on how
to solve this problem what's an example
of a heuristic the best example I can
give you a Urist ik comes from the book
and then the movie Moneyball people know
about the book and movie Moneyball so
this is about the Oakland general
manager Billy Beane and the heuristic
that people used to use in baseball and
assembling a big team of baseball
players is they would send old baseball
players out to watch them play and sort
of says you know I think this guy is
better than that guy base
on how he looks and the big innovation
that Moneyball talks about is Billy
Beane said you know screw how people
look give me their statistics and in
particular both in the book in the movie
he talks about how do you assemble a
lineup in a baseball team you add up
their on base averages that's a simple
heuristic is that the right thing to do
obviously not but it's a rule to get you
a decision you get a team out on the
field which is maximized the sum of
their own base averages you got a team
out there and you know you hope it's a
good heuristic so what I'm doing this
isn't a project that I'm doing with a
former student now with Bocconi named
Alejandro frontage some of you may know
Alejandro what we're doing is we are
looking at different heuristics for
solving this problem over here and
seeing how well they perform based on
simulations now we have no idea how they
perform relative to the optimal you
ristic because no or the optimal
strategy cuz nobody knows what the
optimal strategy is but at least we can
say this heuristic is better than that
and to give you an example a simple
heuristic which you can find in
textbooks on on managerial accounting is
the heuristic does the person pay for
himself or herself I hire this person
this person this person say this is the
team that I assemble I let them work
together for a few months and then I say
ok how much value has this guy generated
how much has he cost me in terms of
salary has he paid for himself if he
does I'll keep him if he hasn't I fire
ok there's a heuristic terrible I mean
you can quickly figure out even
theoretically why but that eristic just
it is bad heuristic on the other hand
there's a closely related heuristic
called the incremental value heuristic
which actually does pretty well against
all other heuristics but one there's one
your estate that we find in the paper
that does great the only problem is it's
a really hard you ristic to implement I
mean it takes a lot of computer power
just to get the heuristic to work
but so what's the point of this what
we're trying to do is we're saying look
we can't solve this problem but this is
an important problem in dynamic choice
people facing this sort of problem you
know they're going to use heuristic what
your istic what can we discover by
simulating this situation which
heuristic seem to do well why did you do
well when do they do well okay now uh
there's been in economics literature
this is something that keeps coming up
like every ten or fifteen years there
was a period of time in the late 70s
through the late 80s where people were
interested in heuristics for learning
what information can be gained from
market prices and I've got one paper
there with Margaret Bray although Tom
Sargent who used to be at Hoover and the
Economics Department has now gone to NYU
Tom is the real hero of this particular
literature in particular if you have a
taste for books in economics Tom has
this brilliant book called the conquest
of American inflation which describes
what happened in the end of the Carter
Administration and the early days of the
Reagan is rationed why is it that all of
a sudden we got rid of stagflation we
got rid of the inflation part of the
inflation his story is basically that
the way economists thought about
modeling the economy was with a
heuristic called ordinary least-squares
regression so they were regressing that
they they knew the model that they were
using the statistical model they were
using was not right but you know it was
close and so we'll pretend like it's
right we'll do what it says and I
basically what he said is when you run
ordinary least-squares regression on the
data they were looking at they got lucky
right the policy prescriptions that came
out was just you know by luck they got a
series of numbers that told them to do
what was right they never would have
figured it out on their own very nice
book then you know a few years later
there was a literature on how to play
games against random opponents and this
is something I've you know I wrote
bunch of papers with a guy named drew
food and Burdwan and now as I said I'm
looking at precisely this kind of
problem precisely this problem will be
here with Alejandro okay so I've got
five minutes left and I was hoping to
leave a little bit of time for questions
but here's my bottom line dynamic
decisions made by economic actors
they're the most important decisions
economic decisions that people make and
they're the ones that we really want to
understand the best unfortunately the
way that economists go about trying to
understand those decisions they use the
sauce whoosh model they use it over and
over again and it's inadequate even as
an as if model it just doesn't really
capture what goes on you know this has
been a 3040 year battle mainstream
economists resist moving away from sauce
whoosh because they think well you know
you're not being rational anymore
you know right we know what rationality
is and this is saying people behavior
rationally and if we do that you know
will become sociologists tomoow get paid
like sociologists don't want to do that
at all but you know the business of
economics that you say the business of
economics ought to be in modeling how
real people make economic decisions and
not have some ideal people from another
planet do so and if that gets us the
sociologists salaries that's too bad so
you know I've spent 40 years nibbling
around the edges of dynamic choice I
hope the discipline will begin to take
some bigger bites out of this subject
because it's really really important and
they don't do a good job of it at all